one
two
three
hi i'm amina kasem and today i'll be
answering your questions on twitter this
is baking support
[Music]
first up we have
at click hole bot how do bakers decide
what temperature to bake at so i kind of
see a trend in most baking is 350 but
there's so many different unique things
that you can be baking a meringue can go
low and slow something else will want
fast heat so you can crunchify the
outside i think you have to go
specifically to what you're making just
because if you bake something too hot
you'll burn the outside and you'll have
raw dough on the inside if you bake
something too slow your cookies could
just sort of melt away instead of
keeping their form and actually being
cooked inside so depends on what you're
making at kate underscore neil at this
point i'm not sure if i'll ever
understand the difference between baking
soda baking powder or cornstarch baking
soda needs acid and liquid in order to
activate but we're using that usually on
denser things like cookies then we have
baking powder which only needs liquid to
really activate and that is a more
controlled temperature those are cakes
airier lighter fluffier things
cornstarch though the way i do use it a
lot in baking now that i think about it
is in baking spray i use a lot of baking
spray in my pans to let them release
them really fast and the difference
between a cooking spray and a baking
spray is basically that a baking spray
has cornstarch in it so it will
very very easily release the goods
at jimmy shaw i'm not good at baking do
you use salt when baking cupcakes all
right jimmy let's talk about salt for a
second because i love salt it is
actually a flavor enhancer so you can
definitely add a little bit of salt here
and there in different recipes but make
sure that you are checking what the
recipe is and what it calls for i
personally love sprinkling a little bit
of sea salt over my cookies just before
i bake them no matter what kind i'm
doing because salt enhances flavor and
who doesn't want to enhance their
cookies up next we have don't tell
scotty
okay but when making cupcakes what is
the deal with frosting how can it be so
difficult to make i refuse to stop
baking cupcakes until i've mastered a
perfect cream cheese frosting if you
prefer buttercream get out of my life
same girl i am a cream cheese to the
core on every flavor of cake my bakery
we only use cream cheese frosting so i'm
with you one thing that i love about
cream cheese frosting is you can sort of
do one one one and i know that just
sounds crazy so i'll break it down one
stick of butter
one bar of cream cheese and one 16 ounce
bag of powdered sugar but you could add
a little bit vanilla at the end but the
ratio should just be where you still
have it creamy and rich and thick but
it's not too sweet but that is my
favorite favorite cream cheese recipe
and it's so easy to remember when you're
out shopping 111. at horror morty hello
guys i need a cake i think it's called
an explosion cake i want it for myself
well
i can't send you one but i can
definitely show you how to make one here
we have six layers of cake and they are
six inch rounds that i baked them in
here i have my cream cheese frosting so
i'm gonna start by doing one ring
doesn't need to be perfect and i'm gonna
start with my bottom layer you're going
to see that i pressed it down and it
allows the cake to not move around whoa
magic and then we're going to do another
ring
there we go
you don't want to get any frosting on
the inside because that's we're going to
fill it with sprinkles fresh frosting is
the best room temperature butter and
very cold cream cheese is the way i do
it color is very important too i mean i
think you can see how vibrant my colors
are but i use gel food coloring my
sprinkle explosion mix gonna fill it all
the way
to the top and don't be scared don't be
shy you actually want to make sure that
the sprinkles are coming a little bit
higher than the cake because don't
forget we still have
more frosting to do a lot of people like
to trim the top of the cake so that it
becomes very flat looks professional and
clean my easy trick of getting something
flat and perfect is
flip it over
and that my friends is how you make a
rainbow explosion cake at chiang fang
wow what a perfect timing she's asking
how do you frost a cake
tada the first step in frosting a cake
for me is crumb coating we're going to
do a very very very thin layer of
frosting all around the cake all we're
trying to do is seal in the crumbs my
favorite tool
i literally keep it in my back pocket
because it's ready to go
it's a cake scraper we don't have a cake
scraper with a spatula a butter knife
anything we'll do okay so i've added a
little bit more frosting and now we're
ready to actually frost it this layer
doesn't need to be too thick you're just
going to keep rotating it and rotating
it until the cake scraper does its thing
and i want to just let you guys know i'm
not applying a ton of pressure to it i'm
just lightly making sure that we are
scraping off anything that's in too much
frosting and then filling in anything
that's a hole and you just want to make
sure you're cleaning it off
because you don't want the sprinkles
sticking to the board you want the
sprinkles sticking to
the cake there's so many different ways
that you can cover a cake with sprinkles
my favorite tool is my right hand
what i do is i scoop as many sprinkles
as i can into my hand and i'm just going
to slowly glide not applying too much
pressure but just enough so the
sprinkles are sticking you're gonna go
straight over
and try and get
as much as you can
just tilt the slightest bit
tada
sprinkle explosion cake okay now the
moment we've all been waiting for we are
going to cut into this explosion cake
here we go
and you want to make sure you're cutting
very big slice all the way down to the
center
one two
three
and there you have it a sprinkle
explosion cake at lily gabo swan serious
question why do cupcakes and cookies
literally have the same exact
ingredients but have completely
different textures and taste nothing
alike
they don't have the same exact
ingredients because here we're talking
about ratios ratios are so so important
i'm from mexico when you think about
chilaquiles or enchiladas or just
different mexican dishes they also carry
very very similar ingredients but taste
different because they have different
textures and different ratios once you
start messing around with that you can
create so many different dishes up next
we have fee i'm a failure why is my cake
so flat first of all feet you are not a
failure you just made an amazing dessert
so let me describe this to you she has
here an upside down pineapple cake with
cherries like going for it and it's very
very thin but actually it doesn't look
like there's anything wrong with it the
texture and the color look amazing i
think what you did wrong here is that
your pan was too big so if you want a
fluffier cake use a smaller pan and that
way
it'll be fluffier
miss camille oh i see sprinkles in here
what are sprinkles even are they just
colorful sugar but why don't they taste
like sugar actually we have sprinkles
right here so
there's so many different kinds when
you're talking about a non-purell
they're the teeny tiny little circle
balls that i cover my cakes in and those
are actually really crunchy and those
are made out of sugar more traditional
american sprinkle it's actually gel
based which gives it that texture that
when you squeeze it it sort of instead
of popping or cracking it sort of has
this gel
texture at envy slope literally why do
all my cookies end up so flat i'm doing
everything right let's talk about flat
so when your cookie is too flat there's
a few things that could go wrong there
the first one being if your dough is too
warm or your butter is too warm before
you put it into the oven then it's
already instantly going to start
flattening out as it hits that heat it
can also be too flat if you're putting
it in the oven at too low of a
temperature because low and slow is not
a friend to cookies basically it just
starts flattening out the dough and
never really taking a shape but
still tastes good you also don't want
the temperature in your oven to be too
hot because then what happens is your
cookie almost starts to shrink quite the
opposite of the flattening and it gets
very very hard and the outside is hard
and overly brown but the inside could
actually still be a little bit raw which
is not something that we want
under baking your cookies i know a lot
of people love a doughy gooey cookie but
under baking your cookie can just be
really terrible because as you can see
it just bulges in the center and that
means that it didn't even completely
cook through
to even get the right cookie shape
lastly
we have a perfect cookie 350 degrees
cold cold cold dough perfectly put in
scooped out of a ball and baked
perfectly just for me
at lexi lane question when making
cupcakes do you fill the entire baking
cup or just a little bit if you're using
a liner i usually do about two thirds of
the liner because you want
it almost to rise that third portion
here plus the little top over so you
just have enough room to decorate and
it's nice and domed because your cupcake
will rise
more than whatever you put in so rule of
thumb two-thirds the black heart king
okay how do i get good at baking i keep
trying but i can't do it right one good
rule is to take it as if it was science
i personally use a scale but if not just
try and make sure that you're using your
dry measuring cups for your dry cups
your wet measuring cups for your wet
ingredients and definitely never mix
those another good rule is actually to
be patient don't try and get in there
early i see so many cakes that end up
being like tipsy because you're frosting
it when it's too warm just be patient
give it that time it needs to cool or
proof or whatever it is the baked good
wants to do at the very least you get to
eat a lot of sugar right at scud
this is not a joke can you make your own
sprinkles at home somehow and make them
pink you could totally make them at home
you just need to have a very very thin
tip on the piping bag look up a great
recipe there's so many easy ones make
sure you're mixing in your color
beforehand put it into that piping bag
and you're just going to make really
long thin lines over and over and over
again and once you've baked them i like
to crack them or you could just crack
them like spaghetti and if you want to
go even crazier luster dust them and
make them sparkle
let's see who's next we have at eccos
and void how do bakers make meringue is
that even possible so possible so
delicious takes a little bit of time
with a lot of egg yolks but the key is
meringue powder put a little bit in into
your egg whites and sugar and you
basically have to let them whisk
forever and ever and ever until you get
this peak white which is just beautiful
and it looks like a mistletoe version of
frosting i don't even know what i'm
describing but it's amazing and you can
make meringue cookies up next we have
atheian christina k
watched all these buttercream tutorials
and hmm i don't have a cake scraper or a
ruler this is going to be very
interesting it is interesting but
interesting can be fun you could also
use the back of an offset spatula you
could probably use a butter knife i dip
my knife in a very hot cup of water wipe
it off and since then the butter knife
is hot it'll easily smoothen off the
little corners and then if not just do a
fun design it doesn't need to be perfect
cover it in sprinkles at hd iln why are
my cupcakes so empty i think if you're
getting air pockets inside of your
cupcakes one thing i recommend is once
you've poured your batter into the tin i
give it a little tap tap tap on the
counter and that evens out my batter but
it's also going to release some of those
air bubbles so that you don't have huge
pockets inside but you could just call
this an eclair and say you succeeded up
next we have at kt lauria baking twitter
can you please explain the chemical
process that turns my perfectly tasty
sugar dough into utterly mediocre
cookies they're not mediocre cookies
once you bake them but you are baking
everything together when you're tasting
it you're probably loving those little
grains of sugar that are just raw right
and once they get melted into the cookie
they're blending with that butter so
maybe up your sugar a little bit or dust
them on top roll them around in some
sugar when you bake them because it
sounds like you have a sweet tooth
olivia at the northernest okay i've got
a big birthday cake question i love
birthdays do you like that thick white
fondant icing on birthday cakes or no
no
i am not a fan of fondant whatsoever the
texture of fondant whether you're using
a marshmallow or a sugar base it's
basically like a play-doh right and you
can play with it you can color it you
can roll it out it's very sweet and it's
edible but i wouldn't say it's delicious
for the most part i mean let's be real
we're not making bananas here you
shouldn't have to peel your cake to eat
it i want to lick my frosting off
at on the lives what's the hardest thing
to bake and why is it cookies i don't
think it's cookies to be honest with you
i think that maybe the expectations that
people carry on what they want their
cookie to look like versus the cookies
they're actually making could be a
little bit different but the hardest
thing for me to bake i would have to say
are souffles you know when you order
dessert at a restaurant they always tell
you if you want the souffle please let
us know in advance it feels like a trick
where they're feeding you order the
souffle number one they are feeding you
order the souffle definitely always
order the souffle and number three it
does take forever it's something that is
rising slowly right it's not something
that's just being baked like a cake it
has this mousse texture it's fluffy it's
light it's airy so it's temperature
sensitive and it needs to be in there
long enough for it to rise it rises so
perfectly like a puffy cloud and
it's delicious but that's way harder
than a cookie up next we have
at rotis can i replace butter with i
can't believe it's not butter when
baking cupcakes technically you can but
they're not going to come out the same
because it's not butter right if you
want to use a replacement without
lactose green valley actually makes a
butter that is identical to butter and
will melt and act the exact same way
i've had so much success with it at amy
v 303 am i the only one that uses milk
instead of water when making cupcakes i
hope not i think you're referring to box
mix cake and they do always say to use
water and oil or eggs but 100 you should
replace the water with milk so water
obviously evaporates doesn't add flavor
milk has a fat content just like you
would with butter and it just makes for
a way better baked good
all right that's all the questions we
have for today i hope you guys all
learned something i certainly had so
much fun all i know is that i'm going to
go off eat a whole lot of cookies
whether they were flat or not